today's topic the adam levine business
what happened i don't think it's gonna
get better if you haven't seen part one
go watch it i'll put the link down in
the description but essentially
ig model comes out the story the fact
that she was sleeping with uh adam
levine who was a married man claims she
was manipulated yadda yadda
and then adam hits her up after the
interfere and he's like oh i want to
name my child after you
that's crazy as far as naming his child
after his mistress
i thought that was bad
and i really did
and then i found out his other child's
name is dusty rose
and
i said this [ __ ] is sick this is a
sickness
therefore we do not want it
huh
dusty rose levine
dusty
[ __ ] like wait wait a minute wait a
minute
dusty like what i call you when you
don't care about your fit yay
dusty like what you call yourself
when you don't care about your feet what
are these [ __ ] why are you spraying
right now
what is this [ __ ] friendly fire that
you engaged in
nah nah nah nah nah why are you engaging
in friendly fire throwing fighters we
had a common enemy and for no reason you
just turned into a backstabbing [ __ ]
hey what's up i'm not backstabbing
nothing what
adam levine i'm right next take a shot
to this yeah no we know the demo was
going on and basically you called
yourself
the child of [ __ ] adam levine that's
[ __ ] up on what you talking about
that's what you're saying dusty rose
not the rose part okay
that's [ __ ] up though anyways moving
on bro listen so back to the topic
that's crazy this man's already been
sick in the head for a hop um she came
out with another part
i just wanted to make a part two um
i feel like it's obviously necessary
um hindsight is
20 20. i initially
wanted to
go in and talk about how remorseful i
feel and how embarrassed and disgusted i
am with myself but
i
didn't want people to look at it and
think like oh she's playing the victim
but just the fact that you're saying
that you've been manipulated when it's
not that i was young i was this i was
that that's just that's just
you said that everybody knew
so you knew as well
and now you're gonna pull out the car
that you know i've been manipulated and
stuff like that and stuff like that
but then but that's you exactly you
don't need to be like i feel remorse
because just in the first thing that you
said
that's what it sounds like
there was an even worse line she says i
mean my morals were unknowingly
compromised i was completely manipulated
yes
you [ __ ] you didn't know that [ __ ]
with a dude who got a ring on and still
married is compromising your values at
22. i knew cheating was wrong when i was
12
yeah
and you didn't know at 22 yeah no you
knowing yo reversal whole id
take this bitch's only fans away take
her driver's license away take her
property away if you don't know at that
age that 20 you should not be a legal
adult apparently you're not ready to
handle any responsibility get the [ __ ]
out of here but but but hold on
let's pontificate for two seconds
is it possible that someone that does
something like
what's that face that's me trying to
pontificate my bibles like [ __ ] this
[ __ ]
go ahead pontificate [ __ ] i always got
face bro try
because my body's like no
but you're no no charitability for me
what does your soul say
listen my soul left my body a long time
ago
dusty people don't have souls but
now go
go ahead go go panther okay bro
let's say you do some [ __ ] up
i was i'm trying bro
i'm trying to do it i can't bro okay
is there a is there a way is there a
possibility maybe okay
is it there
is there a possibility somewhere
you need to put your head back more a
bit yeah it's not backing up i was you
see how you're standing up like that is
there a possibility that she does
something that's wrong
and then at some point you do feel bad
maybe she feels bad
so
yeah i got nothing
let's carry on
in reality it had the opposite effect
something i now realized i didn't touch
on enough was the fact that
one of my friends had attempted to sell
it
which i realized yesterday
whenever they reached out to me for
comment
and so i was completely frantic
that is why that video is for one just
so
all over the place
into
why
i didn't touch on some of the things
that i initially would have liked so in
this video i'd like to
address some of those things
i only came forward because i wanted to
kill whatever story the tabloid had the
most important part that i did
definitely gloss over is
the fact that i was under the impression
that their marriage was over i believed
that they were keeping it quiet to avoid
the negative press because as i had said
i was new to l.a so i just assumed that
with celebrities of that caliber no no
no no no no no no no no no and that's
why i feel exploited no because you want
to know hey this is a new form
this is a new form of manipulation
uh you were manipulated how uh i'm
utilizing
i'm utile and he kept quiet i'm new to
la and i just assumed
that's a whole bunch of assumption right
there all right pull up how's the dm's
that's all close the dm's i said he said
he was going to leave his wife
the [ __ ] out of here no no you you get
that [ __ ] out of here
that's all you
this is what i'm saying
as i'm gonna say
do i believe for one second because when
bishop went to la to start tricking
uh all of a sudden grew up conscious and
just like no i don't sorry don't don't
buy it don't buy it okay if you've ever
been to la it's some of the it's the
hugest congregation of slimy
uh
[ __ ] bring the ladder up once you
cross the finish line listen no you
lived in l.a no okay
no and she is she out there doing only
things
and it's fine
you know what i mean what's wrong with
this one it's not what's wrong it's what
i'm trying to say is like you go out
there to make it
and you out here sleeping with
celebrities acting like you didn't know
what the [ __ ] that [ __ ] meant
[ __ ] you in the you in the mecca of
[ __ ] weirdness
hold up
do you does anybody believe
[ __ ] go to hollywood [ __ ] a
celebrity don't think they gonna do
something for them
that they not going
no i'm trying come on bro like stop
stop
uh listen i don't see plenty of dancers
[ __ ] [ __ ] all kinds of major artists
everything every single one of them
every single one of them
was trying to get on dudes and women i
even discriminated i know dudes who
sucks dick and they were straight oh
yeah and they on tour now okay so stop
this is the [ __ ] i don't like just say
what you wanted to do and you were
trying to get on it's cool it just don't
look good but just don't be out here a
friend talk about
i'm new to l.a bish you went there
knowing what it was but it might work
and now you gotta pop it only fans like
come on now stop you taking a bunch of
free trips come on now stop so let me
read his apology oh no
no
okay i'm sorry i didn't want to hurt the
people i wanted to hurt well let's
listen give him a chance a lot is being
said about me right now and i want to
clear the air
i used poor judgment in speaking with
anyone other than my wife in any kind of
flirtatious manner
i did not have an affair
nevertheless
i crossed a line during a regrettable
period in my life
in certain instances it became
inappropriate and i have addressed that
and taken proactive steps to remedy this
with my family
my wife and my family is all i care for
about this world to be this not even
stupid enough to risk the only thing
that truly matters to me was the
greatest mistake i could ever make i
will never make it again i take full
responsibility we will get through it
and we will get through it together
there's one line here that i think is
interesting yeah the only thing i care
about is my family so if you care about
your family only why you post this to
everybody else then
that's what strikes me but maybe that's
not a thing because if you say i only
care about my family and my family only
no you care about the fans how the fan
perceives you
because if you would just only care
about your family and your thing you
will close that [ __ ] in your family and
your family only no you want to display
that because you want to look a
different kind of way well the drama is
public so i think he has to respond
publicly
he has to yeah if someone's talking
crazy about your family that you brought
into this whole thing publicly you got
to handle it publicly
okay you know if you tell something
about me to one of your homies and your
homie gets messy you're not just
apologizing to me you're doing that [ __ ]
publicly too because that's your problem
that's land there in the public so you
guys that's you i did not have an affair
nevertheless i crossed the line
during a regrettable period in my life
okay
this is interesting
so what i think this is saying in
between the lines if you guys are ready
for this
this is one of two things either a
what
you said that
these guys took a break or something and
he was out there [ __ ] and that's why
he didn't have an affair for me
she knows she knows and this is what i
was trying to tell you guys about the
not cheating thing it's like i don't
think folks know how deep this [ __ ] goes
what we see the way rich people organize
their sleeping around even though they
awkwardly say they're in monogamous
relationships between each other they
understand things differently okay
what we would consider cheating for them
is
just part of the relationship dynamic
um
so so here's something i was telling
somebody on stream one time but it's
like
think about your favorite athletes think
about your favorite entertainers okay
no matter what kind of public image they
have about loyalty and this and blah
blah blah this is the truth
there are people who are paid six-figure
salaries to
link up with ig models and then get them
to go meet these athletes
or meet these entertainers that is their
entire job they basically scout women
for these people to go bang they do the
same thing for some of the women as well
depending on what they need
what the facilitator
aka the plug
yes you're absolutely right so
when i see these things about rich
people and this and that and how why are
they staying together it's like because
they already knew what it was the
problem is now it's in the public it's
embarrassing
that's what it is
and that's why i like think about your
favorite athlete your favorite
entertainer with the most squeaky image
i'm telling you right now they got
somebody who helps them find it or they
do it themselves and that's when they're
stupid this guy he was an idiot
all right not because he's out here
[ __ ] left and right and center he's a
[ __ ] idiot because he didn't use the
proper services
there's a bunch of wives in these worlds
who'll tell you just hire an escort
who's reputable don't embarrass the
family that's all they care about
because they already know what it is you
don't need to like it you don't need to
accept it you you can even watch this
right now and say i would never want
that for myself and i could understand
it that's fine i'm just telling you guys
how that world works
okay i'm not gonna say who the athlete
is okay
he was uh i can't even say what he's
doing okay
there was because you didn't even figure
it out they're going to know okay
this is almost there they're going to
know
a friend of mine she um she dances okay
so sometimes she'll dance she gets paid
to do gigs et cetera et cetera so she
was getting paid to do a specific gig
this at least was at that gig
and his with his entourage
he didn't approach her
you don't have to
somebody who works for him didn't
approach her either
you want to know how next level this
[ __ ] is
they make eye contact
he looks away
the
friend of the athlete goes up puts out
the phone right there in front of her on
the table with new contact wide open
unlocked and then walks away
there is not even a single word uttered
between them
because think about it you guys what why
because think about it if she came out
and said oh
save her where's your proof
where's your proof
well there was a phone opened and uh so
wait you tell me that you just saw a
phone unlocked and you assumed so you
sound crazy [ __ ]
were you what i'm trying to say
so all this to say to bring it back to
the original point
these people that have these squeaky
images be at the kevin hearts beat their
favorite entertainers and all these
they're all engaging in affairs
politicians they have these grand orgies
in washington everybody knows what it is
so this doesn't surprise me it's just
that he's an amateur he's an idiot
because he's just out here in the dm
saying stupid [ __ ] there's a couple
things that people kept saying you know
some people were like uh
you know she's just as fault as he no no
no he's the most desperate he's the most
headphone and that's not even a question
and i'll tell you why he's the most at
fault because this is the [ __ ]
who took the vows
he's the one well if she didn't he still
would have cheated you want to know why
because he can
the disrespect didn't come from the fact
that she approached him let me tell you
something okay this is how you know it's
mostly his fault
if you are married somebody let's say
you have a wife okay
hypothetical you got a wife she's a
beautiful woman okay
people taking an interest in her is not
the issue because if you got an
attractive spouse
people are going to be interested in
them they're going to flirt with them
the disrespect and the breaking of the
vows and the issue really arises when
she engages in something that's where
the betrayal happens that's where the
hurt happens
let me put it through you this way
if your spouse never got hollered at
but instead your spouse was the one
hollering at people and getting zero
response wouldn't you feel just as
betrayed
do you understand what i'm trying to say
the only time the betrayal exists is
when it's your spouse engaging in
behavior
if your spouse doesn't do anything
people hollering at him don't it doesn't
matter it's when your spouse tries
imagine if you had a husband
he out here trying to dm every [ __ ]
teenager on the planet no responses you
still gonna be like i might divorce this
[ __ ] because he tries he
messages he's trying that's where the
issue lies so anybody who's trying to
come at me talking to me like no no no
no
the reason why i didn't [ __ ] with the
lady was because she did some [ __ ]
sneaky [ __ ] she did some messy [ __ ] and
then try to act like she was manipulated
into it
[ __ ] please
[ __ ] please so it's just like
listen
i've always told everyone if they
married their relationship don't get
involved with them and if you're gonna
do i still think most of the believers
are the person who's in the relationship
not the one outside of it but just don't
do it just don't do it there's plenty of
single people out there for you to
[ __ ] marry okay plenty of them in
fact we got more single people today now
more than ever and they lonely and
they're sad and they own cats sometimes
or they play video games and spend all
day on twitch okay they're desperate but
maybe that's not what they want maybe
they want millions
well that's what you want and that's
what you got enjoy your drama [ __ ]
anything else
that's a pretty good closer all right
cheers